so you were eliminated last night you
got evicted um now that you've had some
time to sit with it how are you feeling
i'm honestly feeling okay
i wish that there were more that i could
have done to alter
um what's happening but yeah i feel okay
about it honestly i wanted to either
make it to the final five or
be out before jury and i'm out before
jury so i'm
okay at least i'm not one of the first
jury members
um how do you think you ended up here
like what do you think led to you being
a victim
i think that i was in an alliance early
on the slaughterhouse and when that
crumbled i didn't do a good enough job
at attempting to be in a new alliance
until it was too late i started to try
to create this new alliance just over a
week ago and at that point people
already
were in their new alliances so i think
i was a little too cautious
is there something
about your game that you look back on
and you wish you had done
differently like maybe either a moment
or something that you
like did or didn't do
that you feel like maybe impacted you
i have a few things i wish
i kind of went to bed at an okay time
and most of the game stuff happens
around two to four in the morning
unfortunately and i'm assuming that's
potentially when some of the alliances
were formed so i am kind of like kicking
myself or not staying up later and
waiting to like try to be a part of
those alliances and
honestly i wish i didn't choose brent to
be on my team
those are like the big ones where it's
like gosh dang it like this could have
been so different if i made different
choices
that's the game though i know that's the
game i can't change it it is what it is
what was something that surprised you
about playing big brother
i think for me the last week has been
the lack of game talk but i think that's
just because i wasn't in the big
alliances
i really thought there was going to be a
lot more game talk but now that i've
heard about the other two big alliances
it makes a lot more sense why i didn't
why i wasn't a part of it you and derek
x how do you feel about him now where
are you guys at oh if i were to win hoh
this week i wanted him to go home
because i didn't trust him i um ever
since we had our little spat where he
basically said that i was going home
um i i wanted him to leave so i still
like as a person adore him to death but
as a player i'm pretty spiteful
and wanted my revenge